Oho,
drill și la mine.
Da.
Ăsta cred că i mai mare. Dragi pescari,
suntem în Delta Dunării. S a terminat
prohibiția. Am profitat de ocazia asta
ca să ies să pescuiesc pentru că n am
mai pescuit
din primăvară.
Și
am ajuns de luni. Azi este miercuri.
Luni am ieșit un pic. M am plimbat pe
canale, am pescuit la somn. Am prins
trei sau patru
somni micuți moace. Ieri am ieșit pe un
canal la crap, am pescuit la crap, am
prins ciortani, în jur de 10 ciortani,
am avut și vreo șase șapte scăpări.
Am început pescuitul cu cârlige un pic
mai măricele și
aveam rateuri și atunci am pus cârlige
micuțe și am stat mai mult pe trăsătură.
Adică le am lăsat să se înțepe singur.
Nu am mai încercat să l înțep pentru că
efectiv nu se hrănea. Nu se hrănea cum
trebuie. Iar acum suntem pe un alt canal
doar ce m am instalat de 20 de minute,
30 de minute să zic și am avut deja două
două trăsături. Am scos doi pești afară
nu mari. Ciordan 1, kg și dar este vorba
de activitate.
Pescuiesc cu momitoare.
Încă nu am trecut la
la plumbut cu bilă. Vreau să fac lucrul
ăsta astăzi, dacă tot așa o să am cortan
după cortan, o să vreau să pun doar bilă
și plumb in line în caz, adică să încerc
să selectez un pic
Probabil ați mai văzut în clipurile mele
cum pescuiesc eu cu momitorul. Pun nada
pe momitor.
Introduc peleta în în nadă, nu o bag de
tot, o las deasupra și cârligul îl îl
acopăr cu puțină nadă. Da, în felul
acesta sunt sigur că va ajunge pe
substrat
ne fără să fie încurcat firul de rigul
de firul principal și am mai multe șanse
să prind pește așa pentru că momitorul
atrage peștele și atunci când vine
sigur va lua și peleta de cârlig
împreună cu cârligul. Cam asta este.
Pescuiesc cu nadele GDA Fishing, căpșună
usturoi Secret Aroma și la cârlig pelete
de 10 mm și de 15 mm. toate variantele
am prins la toate variantele.
Iar la bile, bilele sunt
bilele de 20 de mm din borcan
și pescuiesc la ele.
Am și sacul de bile de nădit. Am nădit
mai devreme, am diggusit aroma și mai
încolo o să mai nădesc cu căpșună. Am la
mine doar 24 de mm pentru că stocul de
20 de mm se terminase când am plecat eu
de acasă.
Abia săptămâna asta. Ia și am și o
trăsătură.
A fost
a fost o mică trăsătură.
Bun, cam asta este. Suntem pe canalele
din jurul Milei 23.
Pește este
Peștele este
oarecum încă în lacuri. Am vorbit cu
mai mulți localnici care pescuiesc cu
plasele în lacuri și au zis că se prinde
crap și crap mare la plase. Deci asta
înseamnă că peștele crapul este încă în
lacuri. Pe canale sunt mai mult peștii
care nu se reproduc, ciortanii. Dar
așteptăm. Eu voi sta până vineri, poate
până vineri reușesc să prind și ceva mai
mare. Cam asta este. Stați cu mine până
la final să vedem câteva drilluri. O să
încerc să vă mai spun așa câteva tips
and tricks și vă mulțumesc.
Oho,
drill și la mine.
Da.
A se duce în ciată.
S a dus în ciată.
Am tot schimbat locurile pentru că peste
tot se prinde numai ciortan. Am mai avut
câțiva ciortani scoși, dar n am mai
băgat camera pentru că î este destul de
greu s o montez, având în vedere că mă
mut. Am venit acum pe un alt canal.
Pescuiesc la o cioată. O să fac un pic
de nădire ca să scot peștii din cio
boilisele în jumătate, boilisurile de
nădit și o să dau și câteva întregi. O
să dau în afara cioatei ca să
scot cumva peștele de acolo să iasă un
pic ca să se hrănească, adică să
găsească ceva pe substrat și atunci să
găsească și momitoarele mele. Cam atât.
revin așa cu drilluri în cazul în care
în cazul în care o să am. Văd că am o
trăsătură anemică pe cea din partea
dreaptă.
Trage de
30 40 de secunde, dar nu este hotărât.
Cum așteptam, pescuitul este dificil.
Peștele nu se hrănește bine. Am vorbit
cu mai mulți pescari, am vorbit și cu
pescari comerciali care au zis că nu
prea se prinde pește în perioada asta.
Mai este un coleg cu mine, un prieten
care pescuiește puțin mai sus și a zis
că acum a scăpat unul mare.
El a El a prins acolo cum s a pus pe
locul de pescuit. A prins. A scos doi
instant. A prins, a prins doi și acuma a
scăpat unul mare. Deci na, poate intră
și la noi ceva mai mare, că na, vrem,
vrem crapi, nu ciortani. certan la 1 kg
am tot prins.
[Muzică]
Cam ăsta a fost.
Acum a luat o. Ia să vedem. Ăla i.
A luat o, dar e micuț.
Așa pare.
Deci dacă vreți să vă distrați în Delta
Dunării,
la Ciortani,
cârlige micuțe, momitoare, cireașa de pe
tort.
S foarte energici crapii ăștia.
Deci foarte energici.
Tak.
Aici am avut cred că secret aroma de 15.
Da.
Ia
ăsta cred că i mai mare. Se duce
niciodată.
Nu
îl bruschez pentru că ei se duc în
ciată, să știți.
Bețele lucrează foarte bine.
Aici sub arcă tot trage la ceata din
dreapta.
Încerc să l scot de aici.
Frumos, frumos.
Pescuiesc finuț cu cârlige de 10
și nici nu pot să trag tare de el. E
frumos. Cred că este pe la vreo 3 4 kg.
Sper să nu mă înșel.
Oricum, la cum trage, zici că are peste
5 kg.
Deci n are.
Hai, hai, hai. Nu s a terminat drillul,
mă băieți. Na, are 2 kg și un pic, cred,
dar foarte energici.
Ia uite, mă.
Hai că a obosit.
Ia vedeți, băieți, drill după drill în
Delta Dunării.
Mai avem unul aici.
Bună dimineața! Suntem din nou pe apă.
Ieri am terminat partida de pescuit în
jurul orei 6:30.
Am avut mai mult șortan prinși. Cel mai
mare a fost la 2,g.
Astăzi am venit din nou pe locul de
aseară și să încercăm să mai prindem
câțiva ciortani. Peștii mari încă nu au
apărut în deltă. Mai nimeni n a prins
pește mare. Cei mai mari pești au fost
la 3 kg 4 kg. Am discutat cu mai mulți
pescari și încă nu nu peștele mare nu și
a făcut apariția.
Dar ăsta este iunie. Așteptăm.
Știți cum e, în deltă, întotdeauna poți
avea o surpriză atunci când nu te
aștepți. Astăzi o să pescuiesc și pe
bile. O să bag și câteva bile din sac și
de 20 mm și de 24 și o să bag și
bilele din borcan Secret Arom, cele
solubile și să vedem poate intră și ceva
mai mare. Cam atât este dimineața. Este
7:00 dimineața. Deja avem trăsături
specifele trăsături pe care vi le am
povestit și ieri. Efectiv stau la
momitor 7 8 10 minute și încontinuu fac
așa de de vârf. Aici am trăsătură
Da, este pește
și
oho
încearcă să se ducă la ceată.
La fel a țăcănit o
în jur de cinci minute
și abia după aia a luat o. De ce n am
mai văzut până acum astfel de trăsături?
Nu este mare, este tot în ciortan, la
1,g
sau poate chiar mai mic. Imediat îl
vedem.
Deci drillul este superb cu ciortanășii
aceștia.
Hop!
Haideți să vi l arăt și la cameră
imediat.
Da. Deci ăștia sunt peștii pe care îi
prindem
frumos, sănătoși, lunguieți de deltă.
Ne distrăm.
Ăsta a fugit cu ea, dar a fugit spre
mine și s a detensionat firul.
zic ce se întâmplă.
Asta este pe bilă din borcan
și văd că e un pic mai frumușel, să
știți.
Deci bila Secret Aroma. Imediat o să vă
arăt cum
cum arată, cum s a activat. Se activează
foarte frumos.
Uitați cât de frumos se se
activează bila. Cum arată după ce a stat
în apă cred că 20 de minute.
Voi pescui în continuare cu ea.
[Muzică]
Oho, ce ran!
Ăsta a fost mai hotărât.
Tot așa micuț cred că este. Oho!
A scăpat
Pregăteam ceva de mâncare și
a intrat un pește direct pe ran.
Este la fel de agitat și ăsta. Ia uitați
l.
[Muzică]
Folosesc cârlige mici și mai scapă din
ei că trebuie să țin un pic mai tare
pentru că se duc în cioate.
Sta
[Muzică]
la
Dragilor, partida mea din Delta Dunării
este aproape încheiată. Mai stau cinci
minute și plec spre cazare să mi
pregătesc lucrurile și mâine dimineață o
iau spre casă.
A fost o partidă cu de toate. Am alergat
foarte mult cu barca, am căutat peștele.
Am fost să caut pește mai mare decât
ciortan pentru că în zilele acestea am
prins doar ciortan, dar m am distrat de
minune la ciortan. Cred că am prins în
fiecare zi peste 10 ciortani și foarte
multe ratări, foarte multe scăpări. Ăă
motivele ăă la sfârșit, acum pot să vă
spun motivele. Mi am dat seama care este
motivul.
Peștele este foarte apatic, este foarte
mufturos.
Mulți dintre pești i am prins de buza de
sus sau de buza de jos, dar efectiv de
buză nu din interior. Asta înseamnă că
el nu se hrănește bine.
Acuma am o trăsătură la lanseta din
partea stângă. Efectiv ce face el și
acum face același lucru. Ia boili sus
sau peleta și suge din ea. Efectiv trage
din ea, trage doar de peletă și nu ia
cârligul. Și de asta am avut multe
scăpări pentru că efectiv se înțepa
superficial în buza de sus sau de jos.
Am pus câlige mai mici și atunci am
început să am rezultate mai bune. Nadele
folosite și momeliile le am prezentat pe
parcurs. Au fost toate din gama
sălbatică GTA Fishing.
Nada. Am pescuit la momitor.
La cârlig am pus pelete de 15 mm, pelete
de 10 mm, solubile.
Toate, toate solubile. Căpșun, secret
aroma, usturoi. Le am folosit pe toate.
Toate au de randament. Am folosit și
pentru nădit bilele din saci, noile bile
de nădit
și căpșună și secret aroma. M am nădit
cu ele.
Nu știu dacă vedeți, dar este deja un
run.
Hai să vedem. Da,
așa, pe final mai scoatem un cortan.
Am nădit locurile pe care am pescuit. Le
am nădit bine cu bile secr aroma și cu
Ah, gata, a scăpat.
V am zis, se hrănește foarte Se hrănește
foarte greu. Astăzi, în speranța de a
prinde pește mai mare, am pescuit la
bile de 20 de mm. Am crescut un pic și
numărul cârligelor, dar tot ciortanii
sunt pe vad și tot ei își fac de cap. Au
intrat ciortani și la bile.
Bila care s a topit de 20 de mm.
Cam asta a fost partida partida mea.
M am distrat de minune. Am avut parte de
oameni faini. M am întâlnit cu mulți
oameni interesanți în Delta Dunării. La
Mila 23 am stat de vorbă, am stat la
povești, am stat la o bere. A fost chiar
foarte frumos. Pește s a prins foarte
bine.
Dunărea în continuare este tulbure. Nu
am putut să pescuiesc pe Dunăre. Peștele
încă se zice că este în lacuri, așa că
ce mi a rămas mie de făcut a fost doar
să pescuiesc la ciortan. Vă mulțumesc că
ați urmărit până la final și nu uitați
că produsele noastre le găsiți pe
gdaafishing.ro. Vă salut și vă doresc fi
întins.